[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
SHAUNA ISAAC: Thank
you very much.
Thanks for that introduction.
And thank you all for coming on
this very hot Monday afternoon.
The subject of Nazi looting has
been in the news a lot lately.
It seems as if
every week there's
some sort of new Nazi-looted
object that has resurfaced.
There's been two
feature films made
about the subject, "The
Monuments Men" and "Woman
in Gold."
There have been countless
documentaries and books
about this as well.
It is a complex subject.
So I'm going to
attempt to demystify it
a little bit by talking
about theft and recovery.
We're going to break the
lecture up into three parts.
So the first part will
be the theft part.
We'll look at how
the Nazis looted
art and the vast
machinations that they
used to carry out the looting.
In the second part
of the lecture,
we'll look at recovery.
We'll look at post-war
recovery with the Allies.
And then we'll look at
contemporary recovery.
Then in the final
part of the lecture,
we're going to get personal.
And I'm going to talk about
a story of Nazi-looted art
that involved my family.
Through this story
you'll be able to see
all the nuances of looted
art, theft, and recovery.
Why did the Nazis loot art?
It all started at the very
top with Adolf Hitler.
Hitler wanted to create
a monument to his legacy.
He got the idea for
doing this when he
visited Italy on a state visit.
He was always interested in art.
But it wasn't until he
saw these amazing museums
in Rome and Florence and was
in awe by the artwork that he
saw there.
So he decided to create
a monument to his regime.
And what he was going to
do was build a huge complex
of galleries and museums.
This complex would be
known as the Fuhrer Museum.
Hitler chose to house the
museum in his hometown of Linz,
Austria.
Linz was a small
industrial town,
and it doesn't seem like
it would be the ideal place
to house this massive
cultural monument.
A more logical place
would be Vienna.
But Hitler hated Vienna.
Vienna was the city that
rejected him as an artist.
He was actually a failed artist.
He applied to the Vienna
Academy of Fine Arts--
not once, but twice.
And he was rejected both times.
So he wanted to diminish the
cultural importance of Vienna
as a city.
He felt that, by putting
it in his hometown of Linz,
that Linz would become the Third
Reich's capital for the arts.
And eventually, it would become
the cultural capital of Europe.
While Hitler applied
for admission
to the Vienna Academy, one
of the members of the board
felt sorry for him.
And they told him that he had
some talent in architecture.
So perhaps he should go
on to become an architect.
He obviously never did that.
But he did put his
architectural training
to use in that he made
architectural drawings
of the Fuhrer museum.
Then he got an actual architect
to create a scale model, which
is what you're looking at here.
This picture was taken
in March of 1945.
Hitler committed suicide
in April of 1945.
So by this time, it was
obvious that the Nazis
were going to lose the war.
But Hitler was still
obsessed with the idea
of creating this Fuhrer museum.
Part of this obsession as
well was to fill the museum
and fill it with the greatest
treasures of the Western world.
He hired someone for
the specific purpose
of acquiring art to fill the
museum, a man named Hans Posse.
He had credentials, because
he was the former director
of the Dresden gallery.
And Posse's mission
was to acquire art
from all over Europe to
fill the Fuhrer museum.
Not only that,
but Hitler created
a mandate, telling all
state and party officials
that they needed to assist
Dr. Posse in his mission.
As a result, the Nazis looted
art from every territory
that they occupied.
Now, this isn't anything
new, looting of art.
Through wars throughout
history, it's
always been, to the
victor, the spoils.
Pillaging has gone on for ages.
But what makes this different is
that it was highly systematic.
The Nazis actually had
looting organizations.
These organizations
employed hundreds of people.
There were art experts.
There were people that would
come in and take things out
of other people's houses.
There were record keepers.
The Nazis kept very good
records, believe it or not.
And ironically, this
is what the Allies used
and what we use today
to help find looted art.
It was actually very
prestigious to be
a member of this organization.
There were several
high-ranking Nazi officials
that considered themselves
not just great art collectors
but art connoisseurs as well.
So if you were in a
looting organization
and you could create
a pipeline of art
to the likes of
Goering or Goebbels,
you would be in good
stead with Nazi elite.
The Nazis drew up lists
of what they wanted,
even before the war.
They targeted both public
and private collections.
And they aimed high.
They targeted the
Louvre in Paris
and the Reich's
Museum in Holland.
In terms of private
collections, they
targeted families that were
known throughout Europe
as having amazing
private collections,
such as the Rothschilds
and the Rosenbergs.
But the Nazis
didn't stop at art.
They stole just about anything
that you could think of.
They stole books.
They stole musical instruments.
They stole wine.
Here is a picture of bells that
the Nazis stole from churches
throughout Europe.
Many of these bells have
been damaged beyond repair,
because the Nazis didn't
quite know how to store these.
As you can see, I don't
think it's a very good idea
to stack bells one
on top of the other.
Whatever the Nazis
didn't want, they sold.
They sold this to
fund the war effort.
In fact, the Dorotheum
auction house in Vienna,
which still exist today,
was a Nazi clearing house.
If you look at all Dorotheum
records from this time,
you can see how the Nazis
went into somebody's home.
They listed everything
in their house.
They started with the
most valuable things
in the house such as paintings
or sculptures and jewelry.
And they went down
the list and included
intimate personal items
that nobody would really
want to buy such as underwear.
But these were still
on the list of sales.
The Nazis ended up amassing
hundreds and thousands
of works of art.
And they needed places
to store all of this art.
One of the key places
that they chose
was in the musee de
Jeu de Paume in Paris.
Have any of you been
to the Jeu de Paume?
This is what it looked like
when it was a Nazi repository.
And if you look
through this, you
can almost play, spot
the famous artist.
We have Degas over here.
We have a Léger here.
There's a Picasso
here, and on and on.
What was really
interesting about this
was Reich's marshal,
Herrmann Goering,
came to the Jeu de Paume 20
times in the course of the war.
Goering was an
obsessive collector.
But he considered himself not
just a collector, a connoisseur
as well.
When Hitler would send in
his dealers to get things,
Goering liked to come in
and look at the works of art
and touch them and make sure
that they were personally
sent to his castle in Bavaria.
And so here we have the
head of the Luftwaffe,
who should be spending his
time thinking about the war.
But instead, he's spending
an inordinate amount
of time obsessing about art.
As the Allies gained
favor during the war,
the Nazis literally went
underground to hide art.
And they hid art in salt mines.
Believe it or not, salt mines
were ideal for storing art.
First of all, they
were underground.
So they were protected
from bombing.
Second of all, they
were cool underground.
It was cool.
It was dark.
It was dry.
So you didn't have to
worry about fluctuations
in temperature or humidity.
And you didn't have to
worry about sunlight
destroying the works of art.
There are two salt mines that
I want to take a look at.
The first one is in
Merkers, Germany.
When the Allies
came in here, they
found art from more than a
dozen German state museums.
Here is a picture of
General Eisenhower.
Behind him is General Patton.
And you can see they're
looking through stolen art.
This picture was
taken the same day
that General Eisenhower
went to a concentration camp
for the first time.
And he became sick
to his stomach.
What's really interesting
about this photograph
is you can see that
the effects of war
are actually starting
to take their toll
on this great general.
The other thing that the
Allies found in here was gold--
literally, tons
and tons of gold.
So if you see here,
we've got some gold bars.
And then just bags of gold.
Gold was stolen from banks.
Jewelry was taken
and melted down.
But what was most
disturbing was the Allies
found bags of gold teeth from
victims of the Holocaust.
We're going to look
at another salt mine.
It is in Altaussee in Austria.
This has an interesting
story to it,
because this salt mine was
rigged with explosives.
The Nazis felt that, if
they couldn't have the art,
then nobody else should have it.
So they put bombs all
over the entrance.
We have some unlikely
heroes to the story as well,
Austrian miners who were
part of the resistance.
These miners were able to
thwart the Nazi's attempts
to try to bomb this or explode
this until the Allies could
come and save the works of art.
There were some pretty
amazing treasures
that they found in this
particular salt mine.
So let's take a little
journey, shall we?
First, you go down a long
tunnel of whole mile deep.
And what the Allies
found amazed them.
They found work stations for
cataloging and even restoring
art.
And you can see on the wall just
all sorts of paintings here.
There's another
corridor with paintings.
In fact, the Allies found
over 6,500 paintings.
The majority of
these were earmarked
for the Fuhrer museum.
And I do want to look
at a couple of paintings
that the Allies found,
because they're pretty famous.
Right over here.
This is a Frans Hals.
But it's this one
I want to look at.
That is called "The
Astronomer" by Johann Vermeer.
Here it is in all
its beautiful glory.
Vermeer was a Dutch master.
He only painted 34 works of art.
Every single one of
these is a masterpiece.
Every now and again, you'll hear
about a Vermeer being stolen.
And it's a really big deal.
Because it's a huge
loss to society.
And to think that that
could have been destroyed
is just astounding.
You can visit this painting.
It is in the Louvre in Paris.
And honestly, the slide
does not do it justice.
It's really spectacular.
The other famous work of art
I want to look at is this.
Does anybody know what
those panels are from?
The Ghent Altarpiece.
The Ghent Altarpiece
is this massive altar.
It is 11 by 15 feet.
In fact, here we see it.
It consists of 12 panels
by another Dutch master
named Jan Van Eyck.
If you look at it, you could
see all sorts of nice detailing.
Let me see.
It was this panel, this
panel, and this panel
if we go back right there.
Many people consider
this to be the greatest
treasure of the western world.
And it's just shocking
to think that this
could have been gone forever.
Right.
That is a bit about the theft.
Now, let's talk about recovery.
In 1943, the Allies set up
the monuments, fine arts,
and archives unit, also
known as The Monuments Men.
This was set up in an effort
to protect monuments from being
damaged during the war.
So the military
recruited all sorts
of art historians and
architectural historians
to point out monuments
of cultural significance
and make sure that
these monuments were not
destroyed during bombings.
This was also done to help
with the war on propaganda.
The Nazis were
painting the Allies
as barbarians of culture.
They said that the
Allies would come
in, the Americas in
particular, and start bombing
monuments that had been
around for hundreds,
possibly thousands of
years, without a care
in the world about their
historical significance.
The Monuments Men wanted to make
sure that this didn't happen.
But this wasn't
without controversy.
There were some monuments that
were in key strategic location.
So you sometimes
see Monuments Men
bookish art historians arguing
with five-star generals.
But for the most part, the
art historians won out.
And as a result, we still have
all of these famous monuments
in Europe today.
The remit of the Monuments
Men was extended when
the war became a ground war.
And it became obvious
just how massive the scale
of Nazi looting was.
So the remit that was changed to
find and recover a looted art.
But there is another
remit that they had--
and you don't hear much about
this in the history books.
And it was to make sure
that Allied soldiers didn't
take anything home with
them for souvenirs.
And so on the one hand,
they're trying to return art
that the Nazis looted.
But on the other
hand, they're trying
to make sure that the
Allies don't loot anything.
And that did happen.
The Monuments Men collected
vast amounts of data.
And they were astounded
by just how much art
was looted throughout Europe.
This is one of my
favorite slides.
This was taken at a church
in Illingen, Germany.
And here, we see a soldier.
And he's completely
overwhelmed by these stacks
of stolen art two stories high.
The Allies were
finding repositories
like this throughout Europe.
In fact, they found
over 1,000 repositories.
So they created their own
central collection point
to catalog the works and
tried to return them.
The Allies agreed that
identifiable works of art
should be returned
to the countries
from which they were taken.
Here, we have a
picture of looted art
being returned to Florence.
You can see there's a bit
of a celebration going on.
It was just a nice day.
Everybody's really happy.
But this is only half the story.
Once the works of art were
returned to these countries.
It would then be up to
agencies in the countries
to return the works of art
to their rightful owners.
This is where it gets
more complicated.
If the works were
from a state museum,
that's a lot easier, because
those could be returned.
But if they were from
a private collection,
it becomes very
difficult. First of all,
they might not know who
the works belong to.
But even if they did know
who the works belonged to,
the odds of them actually
finding that person
were very low.
A lot of people had
fled the country.
And in the worst cases, people
had perished in the Holocaust.
As a result, there are
museums all over Europe
that are holding onto what
are considered [? errorless ?]
works of art in their museums.
Let's talk a bit about
contemporary restitution.
After the war, families filed
claims for missing artworks.
And it wasn't just artworks.
It was real estate.
It was jewelry.
Insurance claims were filed.
This happened a lot in
the 1940s but started
dying down in the 1950s.
This wasn't really the
priority for families.
The priority was to find
surviving family members
and get on with their lives.
The issue pretty much died
down in the latter half
of the 20th century,
until the 1990s.
And then all of
the sudden, there
was a resurgence in
interest in this subject.
This had to do with more
information becoming available.
There are three factors
that contributed to this.
One was the fall of
the Iron Curtain.
So all of the sudden,
all sorts of information
from former Eastern Bloc
countries was opening up.
Two was that 50-year
privacy laws and archives
were expiring.
So all sorts of
archival information
was becoming available.
And three was the
rise of the internet.
So all of a sudden, people were
putting information online.
And you could do research
from your computer
instead of having to
travel to archives.
Conferences were held
throughout the 1990s
to talk about what to do with
the outstanding looted art.
This culminated it in a
conference that took place
in Washington DC in 1998
called, appropriately enough,
the Washington Conference
on Holocaust Era Assets.
During this conference,
delegates from 44 nations
got together and came up
with a set of principles
of how to deal with looted art.
And again, they were called,
appropriately enough,
the Washington
Conference Principles.
It's a lot of text
for one slide,
so I will summarize it for you.
Essentially, it
says, every effort
should be made to
find and return art
to their pre-war owners.
It gets interesting again.
These principles were primarily
written by the US State
Department.
And delegates from
Europe weren't
too pleased with the fact
that America was telling them
how to deal with European art.
So in order to make
sure that everybody
signed these principles,
they were made non-binding.
So that means, ethically,
you should do the right thing
and return looted art.
But legally, you don't have to.
A follow-up conference
was held in Prague in 2009
where a similar
set of principles
was ratified by 46 nations
called the Theresan
Declaration.
But again, these principles
were non-binding.
Fortunately, a
substantial amount of art
has been returned.
But there are still
thousands of works that
are out there that are missing.
The latest estimate is that
there are 350,000 works of art
that are still at large.
Families are searching for them.
And as I mentioned,
museums throughout Europe
have works in their
collections that they
know were looted by the Nazis.
In France, for
instance, in museums
such as the Louvre, the
Pompidou, the D'orsay,
and other state museum, there
are over 2,000 works of art
hanging on the walls.
These have an official name.
They're called MNRs, or
Musee Nationale Recuperation.
And they're waiting for families
to come in and claim them.
In the meantime, they are
considered [? errorless. ?]
And the states are
displaying them.
So what do you do if
you are a claimant
and you want to
search for looted art?
Probably the easiest
thing to do is contact
a claimant organization.
There are several good claimant
organizations out there.
Many of them are
charities as well.
There are also law
firms that specialize
in restitution of looted art.
This was not a
specialty 20 years ago.
But as high-value works of art
are being returned to families,
there's a lot of money
involved in this.
So now, there are law firms
that specialize in this.
If you don't want to go
through a claimant organization
or a law firm and do your
own research, what I always
tell people to do is start
by getting a family history.
Know what happened to your
family members before the war,
during the war,
and after the war.
Then get an idea of
what objects were taken.
And if you have
any documentation,
it helps a great deal.
Documentation can
be photographs,
photographs especially
of the works in situ.
I came across a picture of
people looking for a painting.
And there are these lovely
elderly ladies playing cards
with this beautiful
painting behind them.
And that did help.
There are also paintings that
are left to people in wills.
So they're mentioned there.
If they're famous works of
art, they could be in catalogue
[? raisonnés, ?] which lists
works of art by a particular
artist, or even past
insurance claims.
The other thing to do
is, once you find out
an object is stolen
or looted, register it
on a stolen art database.
The biggest stolen art
database is called the Art Loss
Register.
And if you are a dealer
or an auction house that
has a good reputation,
you do your due diligence,
and you check the
Art Loss Register
before you sell anything to
make sure the works of art
are not stolen or looted.
There are lots and lots of
databases of Nazi-looted art
now.
Unfortunately, there isn't
a Google for looted art.
So you can't look at
everything in one place.
You do have to
know where to look.
But hopefully, something
like that will be imminent.
And one thing you're
probably thinking
is, OK, let's say you put
something on a stolen art
database and there's a match.
Then what happens?
If it's from a dealer
or an auction house
and they're reputable,
then they won't sell it.
But then it becomes
really, really tricky.
Because for the most
part, the person
who is putting it up for
sale bought the work of art
in good faith.
And they feel really
bad for the family
that this was looted from.
But they're thinking, well, yes.
This is horrible.
But I paid good
money for this, and I
had no idea it was looted.
Then on the other hand,
you have the family
that wants to get back a
piece of their heritage.
So you start to talk about
some sort of settlement.
And settlements can be tricky.
And they can take a while.
Usually, they take
several years to try
to get both parties to
agree on something that they
can both be happy with.
Now, it is complex,
searching for looted art.
But it is something that
happens as is evidenced
by all these cases
that we've seen
in the last 10 to 20 years.
OK, well, that brings us to
the third part of the lecture
where I'm going to talk
about a restitution case
that my family was involved in.
It is a work by an artist
named Egon Schiele.
It's called "Portrait of Wally."
This was a landmark case.
It's changed the way
that museums looted art.
And it's also caused Austria
to create a restitution law.
This was one of the
first major cases
to put Nazi looting
in the headlines.
Prior to that, a lot
of people didn't even
know that the Nazis looted
art, me being one of them.
I had no idea.
And then when I found out that
this happened to my family,
I became really
interested in this
and started working
in the field.
My great great aunt was an
art dealer in 1930s Vienna.
Her name was Leah [INAUDIBLE].
She owned her own gallery.
And she championed modern art.
And in many respects,
it's very forward.
Because you don't have too many
female gallery owners in 1930s
Vienna.
And there aren't too many
that championed modern art.
She dealt in works by Klimt,
by Schiele, and by Kokoschka.
She owned quite a few
works by Egon Schiele.
But by far, her favorite
was "Portrait of Wally."
In 1938 in Austria,
Anschluss occurred.
And the fate of Jewish
families changed dramatically.
All Jews were ordered to
give up their businesses.
So my aunt had to hand her
business over to a Nazi.
A Nazi named Friedrich
Feltz acquired her gallery.
And he came to her
house one day to get
her to sign some paperwork.
He saw "Portrait of Wally"
hanging on her wall.
And he said, I want that.
Give it to me.
And she said, no,
you can't have it.
It's mine.
It has nothing to
do with my gallery.
It's part of my
personal collection.
He said, I don't care.
Give it to me.
They argued for
a good half hour.
And finally, her husband
said, just give it to him.
You know what he's capable of.
So reluctantly, she handed
"Wally" over to him.
And one of the things
that he was capable of
would be revoking
their exit visa.
So they fled for
London the next day.
When my aunt moved to
London, she actually
set up own gallery here in
London, another modern art
gallery.
And she was actually one of
the first people credited
for bringing German and Austrian
expressionism to the UK.
After the war, she started
searching for "Wally"
and she found that it was in
the Belvedere museum in Vienna.
The Belvedere was the
Austrian state museum.
So my aunt wrote the museum.
She explained the
circumstances of loss.
And she asked for
her painting back.
What do you think
the museum said?
No.
You've can't have this.
This belongs to us.
Sorry.
She wrote letters.
She hired lawyers.
But she had no luck.
In 1953, a young
Viennese ophthalmologist
named Rudolf Leopold sought
her out in her London gallery.
Leopold was obsessed
with Egon Schiele.
He thought that he was the
reincarnation of Schiele.
He touched up works by
Schiele even though he didn't
have any artistic training.
His goal was to amass
the largest collection
of works by Schiele ever.
He knew my aunt's reputation
as a dealer in works
by Egon Schiele.
So he asked her to help
him find works by Schiele
to build his collection.
She said she would.
But in return, could he help her
get back "Portrait of Wally"?
He said that he would.
She hadn't heard from
him for a little while.
Then the next thing she knew,
he ended up owning "Wally."
Again, she wrote letters.
She hired lawyers
but to no avail.
She died in 1969 having
never gotten back
her beloved portrait.
The story is not over.
Let's fast forward to 1997.
By this time, Leopold had
amassed the largest collection
of works by Egon
Schiele in the world.
In fact, he has his own museum
in Vienna called the Leopold
museum.
Have any of you been there?
In 1997, he agreed to
loan several key pieces
from his collection to
the Museum of Modern Art,
or MoMA in New York.
This was a big deal.
Schiele was becoming a very
fashionable artist by then.
And this was the first time
that so many works by Schiele
would be seen on that
side of the Atlantic.
So it helped to raise Schiele's
reputation as well as the worth
of the Leopold collection.
Several key pieces include
a "Portrait of Wally."
There was another piece
called "Dead City."
All sorts of amazing
works were going
to be seeing for the first time.
Our family decided
the best thing to do
was to talk to the press
about how Leopold acquired
works of art in his collection.
"Portrait of Wally" was
not the only looted work
of art in his collection.
And Leopold used less
than upstanding methods
to acquire a lot of works.
So we spoke to a reporter
from "The New York Times."
And she ended up
writing this big article
about how Leopold
used dastardly methods
to acquire works of art.
They interviewed my family.
They focused on two paintings--
"Portrait of Wally"
and "Dead City."
When the article came out,
it caused a sensation.
Citizens of New York, Jewish
citizens in particular,
were aghast that MoMA
would harbor Nazi loot.
So we took this
opportunity to contact
the chair of the
Museum of Modern Art
to see if he could
keep Wally in America
before it went
onto its next stop
in the exhibition,
which was Barcelona.
We knew that, if it left
America and we couldn't
prove the ownership in America,
we would never get it back.
The chairman for the Museum
of Modern Art at the time
is a man named Ronald Lauder.
You might not have heard of him.
But you have heard of
his mother, Estee Lauder.
Ronald Lauder has a
lot of ties to Austria.
He was the Austrian
ambassador in the 1980s.
He was also, or is
also, an avid collector
of Austrian expressionist art
such as Klimt and Schiele.
In fact, the rumor is that
he used his bar mitzvah
money to buy an Egon
Schiele painting.
Not only that, but he
chairs a recovery company
that helps Jewish families
get back works of lost art.
So we thought he would be
sympathetic to our plight.
But guess what?
He wouldn't help us.
He was indebted to
the museum community
and making sure that this
work went to its next stop
on the exhibit.
While this was going on, museums
were taking notice of this.
In fact, all sorts of
museums wrote a joint letter
saying that MoMA had to move
this painting to its next stop
in the exhibition.
This is because
museums were realizing
that, if this work
stayed in America
and there was an investigation
into the provenance
or ownership history
of the work of art,
if they owned works abroad,
other families could
claim for looted art as well.
I'm going to let you
in on a little secret.
Museums do not like to
give back works of art
from their collections.
My feeling is, if these museums
consider themselves paragons
of culture, they wouldn't
want stolen or looted
art in their collections
in the first place.
But that was not the way that
these museums felt at the time.
We spoke to lawyers.
We spoke to government
organizations
about keeping the
work in the country.
And they were all
trying to help us.
But things were looking bleak.
In fact, "Wally" was
getting packed up.
And it was getting
ready to be shipped off.
But at the 11th hour, the
Manhattan District Attorney
swooped in and subpoenaed the
painting under the US Stolen
Property Act.
As you could well imagine,
officials at MoMA were livid.
Officials at the Leopold
museum were livid.
A lawsuit ensued.
Now, during this lawsuit, a
couple of interesting things
happen.
Museums began looking through
artworks in their collections
and looking for gaps in, again,
the provenance or ownership
history from the
years 1933 to 1945.
And they would place
these works online
so that people could
begin researching them.
The other thing
that happened was
that Austria was getting
a bit of a bad reputation
for having looted art.
And the culture minister in
her knowledge and wiseness
decided that this
was just really
not a good way for
Austria to be perceived
and wanted to make
a big gesture.
So they ended up
writing a law saying
that, works of art
that were looted
by the Nazis that were
in Austrian museums
would be returned.
Unfortunately, "Wally"
was exempt from that,
because the Leopold museum
was not fully a state museum.
So this lawsuit went
on for 12 long years.
Finally, in June of 2010, we
came up with a settlement.
The Leopold museum ended up
paying our family $19 million
for the painting, which was
the market price at the time.
And they would get to display
it again in the Leopold museum.
But there would be a plaque
next to it stating the ownership
history and my aunts role in it.
Just a couple of other pictures.
This is Egon Schiele's
self-portrait
with Chinese red lanterns.
And this was what he
painted as a companion piece
to "Portrait of Wally."
Those two are now hanging
together in the Leopold museum.
And this is a painting of my
aunt by a Hungarian artist
named Felix [? Harta. ?] In
talking to family members,
the general consensus is, if
she'd known all the fuss made
over her little painting, she
would have laughed at laughed.
All right.
Well, that is the lecture.
Hopefully, I've helped to
demystify this a little bit.
And I'm happy to
answer any questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I'm just wondering if this has--
immediately what
comes to mind is
art that's been sort of
looted through the centuries
through war--
basically, everything
in the Louvre.
SHAUNA ISAAC: And
the British Museum.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I'm just wondering if this--
I mean, I understand
this is more recent.
It's probably a different set
of circumstances to a degree.
But I would imagine this
is also impacting norms
for those works of art.
So just wondering if
you can talk about that.
SHAUNA ISAAC: Sure.
Yeah, well, in the
UK, for example,
it is illegal to deaccession
works of art from museums.
So that means you
can't give them back
unless there's an
act of Parliament,
which is why the Elgin Marbles
have not been given back.
There have been exception for
Holocaust-looted art, which
you can give it back.
They put a sunset
clause in it, which is
going to be ending very soon.
You might have even
seen that in the news.
Somebody's government
officials said
that they were not going to
put a sunset clause in it.
There won't be a
statute of limitations.
But somebody's
trying to block that.
And this seems to be the
case with a lot of museums
throughout Europe.
AUDIENCE: Are there any
rules on when claimants
are trying to claim
any artwork back
on what they wish to do
with the art going forward,
if that makes sense?
SHAUNA ISAAC: Yeah.
My feeling is, once
they get the art back,
they could do
whatever they want.
Sometimes that's part
of the settlement.
And a lot of people think, well,
you fight so long and so hard
to give back or get
back these works of art.
Why are you then turning
around and selling them?
There are a couple
of reasons for that.
One is because oftentimes
it's just one work of art.
And there are a lot of errors.
You can't divide
up the work of art.
But you can divide up money.
Two is that, if it is a work
of art worth a lot of money,
a lot of families can't
even afford the insurance
on the art.
But my feeling is,
once they get it back,
they can do whatever
they want with it.
AUDIENCE: Does that
even mean, if they
want to keep it in their
private collection,
then there aren't any
rules on that either?
SHAUNA ISAAC: Absolutely.
They could do whatever
they want with it.
They could keep it in
their private collection.
They could give it away.
They could hide it
in a vault somewhere.
It's theirs.
AUDIENCE: Are the
differences between art
that was looted by
individuals and there
was in the more sort of
state-sponsored looting,
in terms of recovery,
are there big differences
in the way you see people
trying to provide evidence?
It must be much
more difficult when
it was a person who just
saw something they liked
and to go off the
wall and it didn't
go into the sort of Nazi
administration system.
SHAUNA ISAAC: Yeah.
Oftentimes, it is
a lot easier when
it is something that's gone
through the state system
than when it's a person.
And the rules and laws for
the countries are different.
So somebody might be
living in one country
and find a work of art
that's in another country.
And you're dealing with
different laws in each country.
So that's where it gets very
tricky and very complicated.
And it's like that with
individuals versus states
as well.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks.
That was really,
really interesting.
It sounds like there
was an opportunity back
in the past from your slides
that whether the international
community could have come
together and made binding rules
and didn't do so.
And then you gave a
couple of examples
how individual countries
created rather restricting rules
on actually
preventing-- maybe this
happened even in
the Austrian example
where there's a loophole
in there that [INAUDIBLE]..
Are there any plans
to create sort of more
international binding rules?
And if not, do you have any
hope that there will be?
SHAUNA ISAAC: Funny
you should ask that.
I was at a conference in
September here in London.
And there were government
officials from,
gosh, I don't know,
Austria, Germany,
the Netherlands, the UK.
Somebody brought
up the question of,
are we going to make the
Washington Conference
Principles binding?
They couldn't say,
no, fast enough.
And there are actually
legitimate reasons for that.
It's good to have
this as a framework.
But then each country
has its own laws.
And they want to work
within their own laws.
But in terms of making some
sort of binding legislation,
I don't hold out
much hope for that.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
When was the last time a large
shipment or amount of artwork
has been found in caves.
Because you read a lot of
the news that people think
they found "The Amber Room."
And they're in the mines
somewhere in Germany.
But has there been-- recently
in the past five years,
are people still finding
salt mines worth of artwork?
And do you have any hope
that they're still out there?
SHAUNA ISAAC: You hear
about Nazi trains.
But for the most part,
those end up being false.
The last big, big, big
stack of looted art
was discovered was
in 2012 I believe
with the Gurlitt collection.
Have you heard about that?
Cornelius Gurlitt was the son
of a notorious Nazi dealer.
German customs
officials were wondering
why he had so much money
when they saw him on a train.
They went to his flat
in Munich, and they
found over 1,200 works of
art in his flat in Munich.
That was probably the last
massive haul that was found.
AUDIENCE: What sort
of condition those--
SHAUNA ISAAC: They're in
pretty good condition.
In fact, they are on
exhibit right now.
There's two exhibits going on.
There's one in Bern, because
for some convoluted reason,
Gurlitt passed away.
And he left all these works
to the Klimt's museum, Bern.
So it Bern is during
an exhibition now.
And there's also
one that, I believe,
just closed in Bonn, Germany.
But it's going to reopen
in Berlin in September
if you wanted to visit them.
The hope is that families
will come forward and claim
these works of art.
So we'll see.
Some of are very valuable.
Some aren't that valuable.
But it did cause a huge
stir when this came up.
And there are also restitution
researchers in Germany
who are going through
the provenance of all
of these objects trying to
determine whether or not
they're looted.
Because Gurlitt said that
none of these were looted
and they were all
acquired legitimately.
And there have been a
few claims made on them
and people have gotten back
works of art from there.
AUDIENCE: I was just
wondering if there's maybe
a positive or negative
correlation between the type
of artist versus a
gallery looking to recover
a certain type of artist.
Does that have a positive
effect or a negative effect
would you say?
SHAUNA ISAAC: It
seems like there
are some artists that tend to
be looted more than others.
Most of them would
be modern artists
such as Klimt and Schiele.
And it depends on who
you're talking to as to
whether or not it's a
positive or negative effect.
And how many of you have seen
the movie, "Woman in Gold,"
with the Klimt painting that was
restituted to the era of Adele
Bloch-Bauer?
That was a really positive
effect for the family
and for the lawyer
that worked with her.
But it had a really
negative effect
on the Belvedere which had
to give all these works back.
So I think it really depends
on who you're talking to.
AUDIENCE: Were the works
that Hitler was collecting,
were they the same
ones that he was sort
of condemning as degenerate?
SHAUNA ISAAC: No.
No, the works that
Hitler was condemning
as degenerate were either
going to be destroyed--
but fortunately,
the Nazis realized,
oh, hey, we can sell
these works of art.
The types of work that Hitler
and, by association, the Nazis
liked were Renaissance
works, works
that were ancient
Greek or ancient Roman.
You could show
nudity, but it would
have to be nudity
without sensuality.
So they were much more
provincial type of works.
AUDIENCE: So was Schiele
one of the degenerates?
SHAUNA ISAAC: No.
Schiele would have been
a degenerate big time.
So Sheila, Klimt,
Kokoschka, Picasso, Chagall.
They were all considered
degenerate artists.
And I could give a whole
other lecture on that.
AUDIENCE: So Hitler
was condemning
all of those degenerates.
And yet all of his sort of
high-ranking sort of officials
were collecting
them on the side?
SHAUNA ISAAC: Some were.
It's always more
complicated than that.
Some were collecting modern art.
Some were big fans
of modern art.
But when the decrees went down
that this type of modern art
was labeled
degenerate, the Nazis
couldn't openly collect that.
AUDIENCE: Interesting.
Thank you.
With that, we'll close.
Thank you so much, Shauna.
That was fascinating.
SHAUNA ISAAC: It's my pleasure.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]